here with reaction out kick founder clay
travis along with a republican
congressman from ohio jim jordan
they never would have done it if it was
donald trump
if it was don jr's laptop or eric
trump's laptop jim jordan weeks before
an election but in unison they sang out
the mantra russian disinformation yet
again i guess three and a half years of
that collusion just stuck in their head
and they couldn't think of anything new
yeah i mean this is why today is so
important sean because the left likes to
be able to lie about us we're not
allowed to tell the truth about them and
we saw that with the example you just
mentioned big tech big media democrat
party all colluding to keep the hunter
biden story from we the people just days
before the most important election and
that's why they're so so apoplectic
today the left is going crazy and as you
point out they're going crazy over an
electric car maker who supports free
speech that shows you how ridiculous
they are but that's the power they had
in the power they used 18 months ago in
the run-up to the most important
election we have to decide who's going
to be president united states who's
going to be commander in chief that is
why today is so darn significant the
left the left doesn't want you to speak
if you don't agree with them you're not
allowed to talk and if you try they're
going to attack you they're going to try
to cancel you that all changes today
with elon musk now owning twitter i i
think so and clay let me read this this
was a tweet from elon musk i hope that
even my worst critics remain on twitter
because that's what free speech means
i've been saying this forever i want
every comedian in america to finally be
set free from cancer culture and i'm
offering myself up as a target every
liberal comedian
take any shot you want to take say
anything you want to say
i don't care i ask one little favor in
return just be funny about it say
whatever you want
that because i believe in freedom of
speech i mean comedians can't even you
know tell jokes anymore without worried
about a fit well i guess without
worrying about getting slapped in the
face at this time
well it's a good point and amen let's
enjoy the victories that we've had of
late sean
cnn plus basically lit 300 million
dollars on fire and imploded right we've
got that brave judge down in florida
thank the lord that donald trump
appointed her and she was able to end
this mask mandate and now you've got a
full-fledged left-wing blue checkmark
brigade panic because elon musk as you
just read that tweet is saying hey i
believe in freedom of speech and if you
wondered how much of a rig job we are
dealing with right now at twitter
someone who comes in and says i want to
have content neutral policies that allow
a robust and uninhibited marketplace of
ideas to flourish
is being attacked by the left wing in
this country they don't want an actual
marketplace of ideas they don't want to
debate ideas they want to cancel people
and to your point sean
you know
right now comics are terrified to do
their comedy many places but on college
campuses the most because kids come up
on stage and say hey that was an
inappropriate joke we didn't enjoy this
and this is why we have to destroy what
i think are the two twin pillars of the
democratic party right now identity
politics and a canceled culture the
combination of those two elon musk is
opposing them i think we all need to be
celebrating with great glee what's going
on and think about this uh
i think he will i i take him at his word
i mean that statement was pretty
powerful i hope my worst critics remain
on on twitter
keep attacking me i i thought that was
the best line that he that he made all
throughout this uh attempt to purchase
now we know jim jordan that joe biden
lied when he said over and over again he
never had a single conversation about
hunter's foreign business dealings we
got pictures with joe
hunter and some of those partners we've
got all the text messages that point to
joe's direct knowledge
now the question is if elon musk
ran twitter at the time and stayed true
to free speech and didn't censor the new
york post and let's say facebook didn't
do it let's say instagram didn't do it
and let's say
twitter didn't cancel donald trump as
uh but allow the muellers of iran to
keep their accounts at has happened for
a while
would that elect would that have
impacted the election in your view
of course it would again look at how the
left's going crazy over one platform the
left controls big tech big media the
left controls higher education left
controls hollywood it controls big
corporations it controls big sports it
controls the white house the senate and
the house and they're going crazy
because they're going to lose one part
of one of those just twitter that shows
you the monopoly they have and we still
almost won imagine what would have
happened if the truth would have got out
there to the american people about a
story like this where joe biden said in
that debate my son had no dealings with
with companies with
connection to the chinese communist
party there are 4.8 million reasons why
that's wrong because that's what hunter
biden got paid from cefc the chinese
energy company so yeah what made a huge
difference
yeah what your take on it look i think
this could have been deep and profound
all we were asking for for people to
take a look at it make a decision the
media they played such defense clay they
wouldn't even ask the question they came
up with one talking point it was
regurgitated by everybody in the
democratic party everybody in the news
media everybody all these big tech
companies and that is this looks like
russian disinformation 51 highly ranked
well this is former intelligence agents
uh agency heads they said the same thing
too with no evidence they just lied to
us outright
this is why we need jim jordan and all
of the republicans back in power in the
house of representatives this is why we
need the senate back in republican
control because i believe that if
twitter had allowed that new york post
story to go out first of all everybody
else probably wouldn't have blocked it
right because what we know is all these
big tech companies collude as soon as
one decided they were going to ban
donald trump everybody did as soon as
one decided you couldn't read the new
york post story everybody did sean even
with the numbers that are out there if
20 000 people had changed their vote in
2020 in wisconsin in georgia and in
arizona that's one nhl arena that's one
nba arena in the entire country 20 000
people in those three states donald
trump's president of the united states
right now you cannot convince me that
twitter's decision wasn't a direct
collusive uh benefit to the joe biden
campaign that echoed across all of
social media and this is why it's so big
look i always like to come on your show
sean and wave to all the democrats
watching because they're watching you
instead of msnbc and instead of cnn
that's what the data reflects and that's
because there is a desperate demand for
truth and authenticity in this country
and fox news serves it and i hope that
elon musk for purposes of big social
media can serve that same marketplace
that is desperate for truth and honesty
and i think if he sticks to his guns
that this is going to be a monumental
moment the biggest win for free speech
in the 21st century is elon musk buying
twitter in my opinion
it's going to be interesting to watch
for sure jim jordan last question so we
know that you can't make threats against
individuals or threaten violence uh
on social media nor should you be able
to now how far do you go with freedom of
speech what do you do about overtly
racist people or
virulently anti-semitic language that
people use what should the rules be in
your view
john i think you are on the side of the
first amendment you know the founders
wrote the first amendment it has served
our nation well you air on that side
right there uh this is one thing we are
looking at if in fact the the people
this great country give us the majority
we're looking at how we change section
230 how we reform it what do we do but
if you're going to air you err on the
side of the first amendment free speech
there's five rights under that first
amendment let's honor those rights
all right jim jordan clay travis thank
you both hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else